8 d'abord passer la parole à michel
meunier puis ce sera mots d'olivier qui
vont ouvrir ces échanges et donc à vous
chers collègues
merci à porter à l'époque merci merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs donc me propose de vous faire
un point de contexte et la génèse de
cette proposition de loi qui visait donc
à renforcer la lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel
vous entendez bien la basse et c'est bon
oui alors le temps pour l'adoption de la
loi au parlement entre octobre 2013 et
avril 2016 a été extrêmement long
rythmé par quatre lecture à l'assemblée
nationale et trois au sénat c'est un
parcours que les procédures accélérées
nous ont fait oublier maintenant puisque
ce n'est vraiment plus le cas pour les
parlementaires
cet examen a été ponctuée par des
soubresauts à l'image des débats en
vigueur dans la société centrée
essentiellement sur la question de la
pénalisation de l'acte d'achat sexuelle
par les clients du rac du délit de
racolage passif et de l'admission au
séjour des victimes de la prostitution
les principales autres dispositions ont
fait rapidement consensus maud olivier
tout à l'heure développera mon propos
sur le contenu précis de la loi
ces soubresauts s'explique par un
contexte mouvant en france depuis
plusieurs décennies entre deux approches
de la question de la prostitution
après une approche réglementariste la
france assume une position
abolitionniste depuis les années 60
d'abord au diapason des nations unies
la convention de 1949 pour la répression
de la traite des êtres humains et de
l'exploitation de la prostitution
d'autrui
dans son préambule on peut lire je cite
la prostitution et le mal qui
l'accompagnent à savoir la traite des
êtres humains en vue de prostitution
sont incompatibles avec la dignité
humaine
et la valeur de la personne humaine la
france ratifient la convention de 49 en
1260 et la grave à l'encontre des
gérants de réseaux de prostitution c'est
ainsi qu'ils sont appelés et fait rare
dans un pays ratifient catr la france
crée une structure l'office central pour
la répression de la traite des êtres
humains le crête qui centralise les
investigations la convention des nations
unies de 49 est le fruit de 80 années de
luttes féministes abolitionnistes
ces luttes ont pourtant ouvert la voie à
des détournements de la conception de la
prostitution au nom de la libération
sexuelle que certains ont pu revendiquer
comme une libération de la femme donnant
plus tard naissance au concept d'auto
détermination
la notion de violences infligées aux
corps des femmes par l'exploitation de
leur corps passe à l'arrière-plan à
cette époque au milieu des années 80
l'épidémie du sida est prise pour motif
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
par michèle barzach aux fins de contrôle
sanitaire une proposition qui sera
rapidement écartée en 1994 à l'occasion
de la saisine du conseil constitutionnel
sur les trois lois de bioéthique la
décision de conformité rappel je cite la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine contre toute forme
d'asservissement et de dégradation est
un principe à valeur constitutionnelle
fermez les guillemets donc décliné
auprès du au préambule de la
constitution
dans le même temps la pénalisation du
racolage passif est supprimée comme
l'est aussi supprimer la cohabitation
avec une personne prostituée mais la
france peine à protéger réellement les
personnes en situation de prostitution
en 2001 mission sur la prévention
l'accompagnement et la réinsertion des
personnes prostituées est confiée à
dinah d'eric que nous connaissons bien
ici sénatrice du nord
cette mission avait été précédée par des
travaux de la délégation femmes du sénat
qu'elle présidait au début des années
2000 un tournant caractérisait le profil
des femmes prostituées dont l'effectif
global stable masqué en fait
l'augmentation des femmes de
nationalités d'europe de l'est du
maghreb d'afrique noire ainsi que la
prostitution asiatiques
la multiplication et la diversification
des réseaux apparaissait dans les années
2000 et déjà internet faisaient office
de centrales d'achat et de vente
la prévention et la réinsertion étaient
déjà pointés comme des points faibles de
la réponse publique dans notre pays
les travaux de la délégation femmes du
sénat se concluait provisoirement par
deux interrogations cruciales que je
vous rapporte deux problèmes mérite une
réflexion approfondie celui du client
d'abord faut-il le responsabiliser par
l'éducation ou la pénalisation
il ne saurait en tout et en tout cas
être plus longtemps ignorés et deuxième
problème celui de la protection des
victimes de la traite ensuite
faut-il leur accorder des titres de
séjour provisoires faut-il le faire sans
condition à titre humanitaire audois ton
le faire en échange d'une collaboration
avec les services de police pour
démanteler les réseaux
notre position abolitionniste nous
commande en tout cas de en tout état de
cause de prendre des mesures en faveur
de ses victimes et les textes
internationaux nous le recommande
désormais donc voila c'était la fin de
rapport de la délégation femmes du sénat
à l'époque dans les années 2000
ensuite les années sarkozy
donc c'est un durcissement de la réponse
pénale à l'encontre des femmes
prostituées soul influence des thèmes
politiques liées à l'insécurité à
l'immigration qu'un changement de la
perception habituelle du plus vieux
métier du monde 2003 entre guillemets
bien sûr plus vieille violence pour nous
en 2003 de nouvelles incriminations le
délit de racolage passif la définition
rappeler rapidement le fait par tous
moyens y compris par une attitude même
passive de procéder publiquement au
racolage d'autrui en vue de l'inciter à
des relations sexuelles en échange d'une
rémunération puni de deux mois
d'emprisonnement et de 3750 euros
d'amendé
auparavant seul le racolage actif été
sanctionné d'une contravention
l'objectif affiché en mettant la
pression sur les personnes prostituées
était de les conduire à livrer des
renseignements sur les proxénètes une
faible application de ce délit de
racolage passif dont les effets sont
seulement de déplacer les lieux de
prostitution à l'égard des zones
habituelles dans la plus grande
satisfaction des riverains constat d'une
exposition de personnes d'une exposition
de personnes prostituées à des violences
c'est le rapport de 2012 de médecins du
monde sur les femmes chinoises qui se
prostituent à paris et donc là on parle
de violence physique phy viols subis et
rajeunissement des personnes prostituées
donc sous-entendu les mineurs tout les
incriminations de ce délit de racolage
passif sont désormais celles qui pèsent
sur la loi de 2016 à l'aube de la
présidentielle de 2012 des initiatives
en faveur du renforcement de la
législation pour lutter contre le
système prostitutionnel fleurissent la
mise en lumière par le rapport
parlementaire des députés danielle
bousquet et guy geoffroy en conclusion
des travaux d'une mission d'information
sur la prostitution en avril 2011
le rapport pointe durement les effets
contradictoires de la répression du
racolage son application restrictive et
impressionniste il détaille le
dispositif de répression du proxénétisme
jugé complet mais critique l' usage
variable de sa pénalisation selon les
juridictions
il établit surtout que les droits
ouverts aux victimes ne sont pas mises
en oeuvre et propose de changer la
proche
il recommande de coupler la pénalisation
du client d'actes sexuels dans une
logique d'abandon du système patriarcal
qui présuppose l'autodétermination
la personne prostituée son utilité
sociale à une meilleure éducation et
prévention du recours à la prostitution
considéré comme une violence et enfin il
soutient en outre l'accompagnement
intégrale des personnes prostituées par
des droits des revenus et les logements
garantit une proposition de loi sera
déposée en décembre 2011
non inscrits et une résolution adoptée à
l'unanimité le 6 décembre 2011 à
l'assemblée nationale cette résolution
réaffirme la position abolitionniste de
la france qui implique également la
protection des personnes prostituées
notamment par la répression de
l'exploitation sexuelle d'autrui et du
proxénétisme
la prévention de l'entrée dans la
prostitution et l'aide à la réinsertion
des personnes prostituées en parallèle
au sénat la proposition de loi visant à
l'abrogation du délit de racolage public
d'esther benbassa déposé au sénat le 2
octobre 2012 est adoptée le 28 mars 2013
proposition soutenue par le mouvement
associatif notamment la cncdh son
article unique abroge les dispositions
de 2003 au motif de leur inefficacité
contre les réseaux de l'accroissement de
la vulnérabilité des personnes
prostituées et lui maintient de
l'arsenal de lutte contre la traite
quelques semaines plus tôt la commission
des affaires sociales du sénat avait
confié une mission sur la situation
sanitaire et sociale des personnes
prostituées confiée à jean pierre
godefroy et chantal jouanno le besoin
d'un changement de cap législatif est
soutenu dans la société tout entière en
juillet 2013
200 organisations signe l'appel de
bruxelles qui demande aux états membres
la fin des politiques répressives et
l'accompagnement vers des programmes de
sortie de la prostitution
tirant les leçons de 10 ans d'expérience
abolitionniste en suède et réglementa
réglementariste aux pays bas en
septembre 2013
huit syndicats et associations de
jeunesse appelle à améliorer la
prévention par l'éducation sexuelle en
octobre 2013 100 associations locales et
nationales luttant contre les violences
faites aux femmes
appelle le président de la république à
agir contre l'impunité de l'achat
d'actes sexuels novembre 2013
des magistrats autour du char penel
appelle à agir avec plus d'efficacité
la proposition de loi renforçant la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
est déposée le 10 octobre 2013 par bruno
le roux maud olivier catherine coutelle
et leurs collègues socialistes à
l'assemblée nationale chantal jouanno et
jean pierre godefroy remettent leur
rapport qui pointe l'état de santé
globalement préoccupant des personnes
prostituées et leurs accès au droit
difficile dans les faits il propose la
mise en oeuvre d'un accompagnement
social global pour des alternatives
ainsi qu'une politique de réinsertion
personnalisé indépendant de la
coopération ou non de la victime de
prostitution au démantèlement du trafic
les questions de racolage et de la
pénalisation des clients sont
volontairement écarté du champ de cette
mission tout au long de l'examen de la
proposition de loi un quasi consensus
sur la volonté de mieux accompagner vers
la sortie de la prostitution sur le
renforcement du pilier éducatif
si cette disposition reste en navette
parlementaire car adopter en termes
différents
les objectifs restent communs entre les
deux chambres la lutte contre les
réseaux l'accompagnement vers la sortie
et la meilleure information des jeunes
le clivage est marqué sur l'admission au
séjour des victimes étrangères de la
prostitution sur l'abolition club par
donc l'abrogation du délit de racolage
jugé utile aux forces de l'ordre par
certains est maintenue par le sénat en
première lecture et de très fortes
divergences ont existé sur la
pénalisation des clients un débat
législatif clos qui ne résout pas tous
les problèmes
une approche libérale fondées sur la
vision néerlandaise d'autodétermination
à structurer l'opinion contre certaines
dispositions de la loi ainsi au motif
d'une plus grande vulnérabilité des
personnes prostituées d'une
précarisation accrue et de la crainte de
représailles des clients des mouvements
notamment par médecins du monde ont
combattu fortement la pénalisation du
client
souvent dans les mêmes termes qu'ils
attaquaient le délit de racolage passif
en 2003 cinq ans plus tard ces mêmes
arguments restent courants chez les dans
les associations comme dans certains
services des forces de l'ordre en loire
atlantique c'est mon département en 2020
une déléguée aux droits des femmes
rappelait que la police continue de
mettre en doute le bien-fondé de cette
verbalisation l'un des présupposés
justement décrit par guy geoffroy et
danielle bousquet concernait la
prétendue utilité sociale de la
prostitution au motif qu'elle remplirait
à un service l'exemple de l'assistance
sexuelle pour les personnes lourdement
handicapées était décrit déjà et les
questions éthiques soulevés invitait les
rapporteurs à ne pas tolérer d'exception
législatives au proxénétisme au profit
de l'assistance sexuelle
cette approche est désormais a
questionné par la secrétaire d'état aux
personnes handicapées sophie cluzel qui
s'est déclarée favorable à
l'accompagnement de la vie sexuelle des
personnes handicapées par des assistants
cette approche doit nous alerter en ce
qu'il reste qu'en ce qu'elle risque de
rouvrir des débats déjà entretenus sur
le prisme d'une approche misérabiliste
qui n'est que la résultante de la place
que nous accordons aux personnes en
situation de handicap dans la société
d'une part et de la conception de besoin
vital du plaisir masculin qui sous tend
depuis bien longtemps
la justification de la marchandisation
du corps des femmes
voilà madame la présidente parce que je
pourrais vous dire en fin de l'histoire
merci cher michel meunier rapporteur sur
ce texte j'ai aimé le le quasi consensus
c'était un terme à ces élégants pour
quand même cachet des deux grandes
difficultés à avancer sur ce sujet à
l'époque il a fallu beaucoup de courage
à la rapporteure quand même pour faire
avancer ce texte et faire voter ce texte
je sais tout de suite la parole
également à madame la rapporteure mots
d'olivier à l'époque et co auteurs de
cette proposition à vous madame merci
merci madame la présidente
merci michel tu l'as déjà dit pour
beaucoup de choses mais simplement le
fait de rappeler qu'il y a quand même
fallu plus de cinq ans de travail
parlementaire qui ont été nécessaires
pour que la loi soit promulguée me
semble important donc effectivement
c'est en décembre 2011 qu'une résolution
avait été voté à l'unanimité des groupes
politiques à l'assemblée nationale à la
suite du rapport de danielle bousquet et
guy geoffroy en 2012 la délégation aux
droits des femmes de l'assemblée
nationale s'est saisi de cette question
et après un an d'auditions a présenté en
septembre 2013 un nouveau rapport avec
40 recommandations
une commission spéciale transpartisane a
alors été constituée et à l'issue de son
travail une ppl a été déposée et votée à
l'assemblée nationale en décembre 2013
alors c'est là qu'ont commencé les
vraies batailles en interne des
assemblées et en externe avec une presse
et des lobbys proxénète vent debout sur
un aspect particulier du texte la
responsabilisation des clients jusqu'à
présent le sort des personnes
prostituées ne léser mauvais pas
beaucoup mais tout à coup il fallait
défendre la liberté sexuelle
celle des clients bien sûr trois ans
neuf corps législatif modifiée de
nombreux décrets d'application plus tard
les dispositions du texte sont déployés
et les politiques publiques concernées
évolue lentement mais elle évolue
quelques chiffres quand même faut savoir
qu'il y a environ 30 à 40 mille
personnes prostituées en france 400
milles en allemagne pays réglementariste
l'un d'entrés moyens dans la
prostitution et de 14 ans il y a environ
on comptabilise environ dix mille
mineurs 85% des personnes prostituées
sont des femmes 90% étrangères victimes
de la traite et bien sûr 99 % des
clients sont des hommes
le 6 avril 2016 donc la loi renforçant
la lutte contre les systèmes
constitutionnels a été promulguée a été
voté par don avec ses quatre piliers le
premier pilier concernait la lutte
contre le proxénétisme
des êtres humains non loi contre le
proxénétisme ont sans doute protéger
notre pays contre l'installation des
réseaux de traite
mais la prostitution de rue a laissé
place à la mise en relation par internet
ou par le téléphone est installé à
l'étranger les dans les pays où ce type
d'acte illégal
les proxénètes organisent les réseaux de
distribuer de prostitution de pardon sur
notre sol la loi prévoit maintenant que
les fournisseurs d'accès à internet et
les hébergeurs de sites doivent
désormais à la lune a participé à la
lutte contre la diffusion de contenus
composantes des offres de services
sexuels tarifés le pilier numéro 2
concerne la dépénalisation et le
renforcement des droits des personnes
prostituées et d'accompagner celles qui
souhaitent sortir de la prostitution
l'un des enjeux majeurs de ce texte
était bien de donner des perspectives
crédibles d'insertion personnes
prostituées et réduire la demande de
prostitution allait mécaniquement
réduire leurs ressources et dans le
contexte actuel de pandémie
on voit quelques fois leurs demandes
sont criantes la loi donc à supprimer le
délit de racolage de racolage l'a dit
michel meyniel a dit qu'il était
incohérent avec la position française
abolitionnistes qui considère les
personnes prostituées victimes de
violences et a donc créé un parcours de
sortie de prostitution dans chaque
département une instance présidée par le
préfet est chargé d'organiser et de
coordonner l'action en faveur des
victimes de la prostitution
l'engagement dans le parcours de sortie
ouvre des droits la perception d'une
aide financière à l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des places en centre
d'hébergement et pour les personnes
étrangères
l'accès à une autorisation provisoire de
séjour de six mois permettant de
travailler autorisation de séjour
renouvelable pendant toute la durée du
parcours de sortie enfin exercé des
violences à l'encontre d'une personne se
livrant à la prostitution est désormais
un motif d'aggravation des peines
le troisième pilier de la loi c'est de
renforcer l'éducation à la sexualité à
la prévention la loi inscrit la lutte
contre la marchandisation des corps
parmi les thématiques relevé
de l'éducation à la sexualité ainsi
qu'une information et une éducation
égalitaire à l'estiment de soi et de
l'autre et au respect du corps pour que
soit affirmé que la sexualité ne peut
que se concevoir que libre gratuite et
consenti le quatrième pilier qui a fait
couler le plus d'encre et de
responsabiliser les clients et
d'interdire l'achat d'acteurs sexuelle
depuis 2002 le recours à la prostitution
de mineure ou de personnes vulnérables
était déjà un délit sanctionné l'acte de
recours à la prostitution c'est se
placer dans la continuité des
législations qui ont criminalisé le viol
est fait du harcèlement sexuel une
infraction correctionnel
l'objectif étant toujours de soustraire
la sexualité à la violence et à la
domination masculine
la loi du 13 avril crée donc une
infraction de recours à la prostitution
puni d'une inscription au casier
judiciaire et 2500 euros damende en cas
de récidive la fraction constitue un
délit puni d'une peine d'amendé 3750
euros
nous avons également créé une peine
complémentaire sous la forme d'un stage
de sensibilisation à la lutte contre l'
achat d'acte sexuel
l'interdiction d'achat d'un acte sexuel
est à ce jour la mesure la plus efficace
pour réduire la prostitution et
dissuader les réseaux de traite et de
proxénétisme de s'implanter sur notre
territoire
enfin c'est la solution la plus
protectrice pour les personnes qui
resteront dans la prostitution en
inversant le rapport de force avec le
client elle leur permet de dénoncer les
violences ou les risques sanitaires
qu'ils peuvent leur imposer alors un
florilège des objections que nous avons
le plus souvent entendues et qui
continuent d'ailleurs la prostitution
serait une réponse à la misère sexuelle
or deux tiers des clients vivent ou ont
vécu en couple une réponse trop pulsions
irrépressibles
on a très long très long temps accepter
l'idée que le corps des femmes
appartenait aux hommes et que leur désir
exigé à l'assouplissement immédiat voir
le viol que seule la femme serait
responsable du désir qu'elle suscite
or la vie en soucier
et impose des règles et nous sommes des
êtres de raison et de contrôler la
prostitution ferait diminuer le nombre
de viols
bien sûr ces faux puisqu'on sait que les
viols sont à 80% commis par l'entourage
de la victime 34% au sein du couple et
63% des victimes de viol sont des
mineurs en fait la prostitution
contribuer à diffuser les dés que le
corps des femmes peut être à disposition
à tout moment en payant ou en violant
elles le veulent bien comment nous faire
croire que subir des relations sexuelles
tarifées sous la contrainte économique
ou par la violence relèvent du
consentement du livre choix tout quand
on sait que l'âge d'entrée dans la
prostitution et le 14 ans on sait
qu'elles le font pour des raisons
économiques
jamais pour le plaisir le veulent bien
non elles le font pour survivre et
souvent pour nourrir leurs enfants
il existe un discours visant à camoufler
la réalité de l'exploitation sexuelle
comme de parler de travailleurs du sexe
et faire accepter que le sexe des femmes
soit un produit marchand
c'est un subterfuge pour donner une
fonction sociale valorisante et reconnue
aux personnes prostituées et façon à ce
que toutes les violences
inhérente au système prostitutionnel bon
c'est pas un travail comme un autre
c'est un terme de propagande inventée et
utilisée par les profiteurs de
l'industrie du sexe qui entraînerait si
on acceptait ce terme la légalisation du
proxénétisme
quant au supposé violence supplémentaire
que la loi permettrait il n'y a pas
d'autres violences que celles inhérentes
à la pratique de la prostitution
elle-même ce sont les agressions
sexuelles physiques et psychologiques
qui accompagne souvent la prostitution
et la répétition fréquentes d'actes
sexuels non désirés qui portent atteinte
à l'intégrité du corps des personnes
prostituées des femmes disent cependant
que c'est leur choix soit mais elles ne
sont pas représentatives des peu près de
90% des victimes de la traite des êtres
humains ou des proxénètes et quand bien
même une seule personne prostituée
revendiquerait ce choix
au nom de quoi notre société
décideraient de ne pas protéger toutes
les autres jeux
disait la presse a joué un rôle très
négatif au début jusqu'à ce que certains
journaux ou éditorialistes la défendre
ainsi l'un d'entre eux a dit elle fait
valoir une vision un projet pour notre
société et une fois adopté il paraît
inconcevable de revenir en arrière tant
elle est en adéquation avec son temps
des opposants ont fait beaucoup de
lobbying michel meunier l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure en passant par des
associations nationales dont la mission
est pourtant d'accompagner les plus
vulnérables leurs motivations restent
floues puisque les personnes prostituées
sont les plus vulnérables des précaires
ainsi en novembre 2018 le conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi d'une qpc
une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité par ces associations
mais après examen il a réaffirmé le bien
fondé de la loi pour lutter contre les
profits des proxénètes la traite des
êtres humains à des fins d'exploitation
sexuelle et la veille l'asservissement
de l'être humain et il a déclaré
conforme à notre constitution
alors nous avons été soutenus chacun
chacune à notre place les députés les
sénateurs et sénatrices convaincu des
ministres nous avons beaucoup discuté
expliqué sans relâche sociaux réunis
dans le cycle abolition 2012 par des
associations féministes et des
associations de jeunes par des prises de
position de médecins de responsables
politiques
et bien sûr nous avons été soutenus par
le gouvernement de l'époque plusieurs
ministres femmes surtout on était à la
manoeuvre pour inscrire la loi à
l'agenda politique et c'est sous le
mandat de laurence rossignol à leurs
ministres que la loi a été votée depuis
un sondage ipsos en février 2019 montre
que pour 78% nos concitoyens cette loi
est une bonne chose que 79 % pensent
qu'il ne devrait pas être possible
d'avoir accès au corps et à la sexualité
d'autrui et surtout 85 % jugent
important voire il urgent d'agir
je suis pas certaine que nous ayons eu
la même réponse à ces questions suez a
été posée il y a quelques années la
norvège le canada
il sera l islande la finlande ont tout
aussi choisi le modèle abolitionnistes
et d'autres pays
rob et du monde sont prêts à s'engager
dans ce combat mais ils attendent de
voir comment évolue notre société
française comment elle accepte ce
changement de mentalité
comment nos politiques publiques
répondent à cette perspective d'un monde
sans prostitution alors à nous à vous de
les convaincre
merci merci beaucoup madame la co auteur
et rapporteur c'était extrêmement
intéressante vous avoir ce matin toutes
les deux à la fois cette vision du sénat
mais également cette vision depuis
l'assemblée nationale et dans un
contexte qui était vous l'avez rappelé
assez difficile je crois que nous avons
aussi laurence rossignol qui est
connecté qui interviendra aussi tout à
l'heure puisqu'elle a joué un rôle très
important à ce moment là dans les
difficultés pour mener à bien ce projet
donc on va poursuivre la table ronde
avec la nos invités qui sont en
présentiel sur ma gauche
je leur souhaite la bienvenue également
et également pour intervenir sur et
présenté le rapport sur la mission inter
inspection de décembre 2019 donc ce sera
une présentation à trois voies d'abord
une présentation vision et ensuite une
présentation en présentiel
avec à la fois amélie puccini né jean
elie qui nous présente qui vient nous
présenter tout de suite son rapport
puisqu'elle devra nous quitter à 9h30 et
ensuite on enchaînera en enchaînera
pardon avec pia loulergue représentant
l'igas et madame catherine gay
magistrate qui sont avec nous merci à
vous tous tinelli merci beaucoup madame
la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les députés et
sénateurs
c'est vrai plaisir de venir vous
présenter aujourd'hui
quelques constats que nous avons tirées
de notre rapport interne inspection iga
igas et gj de décembre 2019 et qu'il est
disponible en ligne
alors je vais vous présenter quelques
éléments dans un bref sera très bref
donc évidemment vous pouvez vous
rapporter aux rapports pour plus plus
d'éléments de bilan mais je vais vous
présenter quelques éléments bilan sur le
premier pilier de la loi la lutte contre
le proxénétisme et attraits des êtres
humains
et puis je vous présenterai également le
bilan avec mon collègue pierre ou legs
le bilan du deuxième pilier sur la prise
en charge des personnes victimes de
prostitution alors un premier élément de
constats qui est nécessaire pour
apprécier l'évolution toutes les
évolutions que nous allons décrire c'est
le fait que le phénomène de la
prostitution en france a connu au cours
des dernières années des évolutions de
fond qui sont très importantes
premier premières et l'évolution la
prostitution de rue a diminué et c'est
parfois déportés vers des zones
périphériques tandis que la prostitution
à l'intérieur a augmenté l indicateur
parmi d'autres la part des victimes
identifiées par la police opérant sur la
voie publique est passée de 54% en 2016
à 38% en 2018 et donc la mise en
relation entre les clients et les
personnes qui se prostituent se fait
désormais majoritairement par internet
c'était une évolution qui avaient déjà
été constatés avant même l'évolution de
la loi et que nous avons également
constaté lors de la mission alors en
l'absence de données statistiques très
fiable antérieure à l'adoption de la loi
faute d'avoir mis en place au moment de
l'adoption de la loi des outils
d'évaluation du phénomène nous n'avons
pas pu trancher sur la part de c
évolution imputable au changement
législatif et sur celles imputables à
des tendances structurelles en tout cas
c'est sur les évolutions qui évidemment
conditionne l'application de certaines
mesures de la loi
2e série d'observations sur le bilan que
l'on peut faire du pilier sur la lutte
contre le proxénétisme et la traite des
êtres humains puisque une part
majoritaire de la prostitution passe
désormais par internet
la loi du 13 avril 2016 viser à
renforcer la lutte contre le
proxénétisme en étendant au proxénétisme
le dispositif de signalement de contenus
illicites sur internet
c'est un dispositif qui passe
principalement par la plateforme pharos
plateforme d'harmonisation d'analysé de
recoupement et d'orientation des
signalements le constat que nous avons
fait c'est que c'est un dispositif qui a
encore trop peu mobilisés en 2018 moins
de 200 signalement sur des contenus et
proxénétisme sur internet avait été fait
sur la plateforme pharos alors que cette
plateforme avait reçu cent soixante
trois mille signalement voilà 200
signalement sur cent soixante trois
mille
on voit qu'il ya un accès amélioré à
sion important et le site de la
plateforme et ne mentionnait pas et ne
mentionne toujours pas la possibilité de
signaler des contenus dits sites ayant
trait au proxénétisme ou la traite des
êtres humains et pour nous et il faut
qu'ils soient actualisées pour la
mission il doit être actualisée pour en
faire mention
puisque ces signalements ne sera pas
besoin de ça à faro sont très
insuffisants a annulé deux pour propre
pour le pour le repérage on est
important que les services de police et
de gendarmerie soient renforcées en
matière de cyber de cyber proxénétisme
pour faire d'éveil pour faire des
maraudes en ligne qui sont très
chronophage mais qui sont importantes
pour pouvoir repérer les annonces de ce
type qui sont vraiment les gens on a pu
le constater pendant la mission y en
avait vraiment beaucoup en ligne et donc
ça nous paraît extraits
important que les airs d'histoire en
verser sur ce point une autre évolution
qui a été introduite par la loi a
consisté dans l'abrogation du délit de
racolage pour reconnaître les personnes
prostituées comme des victimes et la
création de nouvelles infractions
d'achat taxe d'actes sexuels lors de
l'adoption de la loi certains services
d' enquête craignez de perdre un outil
de lutte contre le proxénétisme en
arguant du fait que le placement en
garde à vue pour le délit de racolage
permettait d'interroger la personne
prostituée sur le réseau le constat que
nous avons fait avec la mission c'est
que cela n'a pas nui à l'efficacité de
la lutte contre le proxénétisme
on a même eu un renforcement de la
mobilisation des services puisque le nom
d' enquête pénale menée en france sur
ces sujets a augmenté de 54% 1 4 ans
entre 2016 et 2019 dont le même temps on
a constaté une convergence de la
jurisprudence des tribunaux
correctionnels vers davantage de
sévérité en matière de lutte contre le
proxénétisme et la traite aux fins
d'exploitation sexuelle
voilà donc une abolition du délit de
racolage qui n'a pas nui à l'efficacité
des services et une mobilisation accrue
des services toutefois l'infraction de
recours à l'achat d'un acte sexuel qui
était l'autre pendant a créé par la loi
et peut constater à ce jour en 2018
moins de 2000 personnes ont été mis en
cause pour cette infraction
et ces personnes étaient concentrés sur
un petit nombre de territoires puisque
paris concentre la moitié des procédures
alors toutefois c'est quand même un
nombre qui est supérieur à l'infraction
de racolage qui avait été constatée dans
les années précédant de l'adoption de la
loi mais il y à là sans doute un effort
à faire pour constater cette infraction
sur tout le territoire français et pas
simplement sur un petit nombre de
territoires
et puis une des peines possibles pour
l'infraction d'achat d'actes de services
sexuels et le fait d'infliger un stage
de sensibilisation à la lutte contre
contre l'achat de tels services
ces stages sont encore peu développée
avec 100 à 300 peine parents seuls 6%
des tribunaux en développer de tels
stages
tel stage est donc là la mission
recommandé de développer ces stages sur
tout le territoire et d'assurer une
harmonisation de ces stages enfin la loi
avait prévu un dispositif de protection
spéciale pour les victimes de traite ou
de proxénétisme en en danger sur le
territoire français elle n'a pas encore
été utilisé donc n'avons pas pu faire de
bilan de son application
voilà brossé à quelques grands traits
les évolutions constatées en matière de
lutte contre le proxénétisme
il revient maintenant au deuxième pilier
de la loi sur l'amélioration de la prise
en charge des personnes victimes de
prostitution
la loi a créé un parcours de sortie de
la prostitution et puis une commission
départementale de lutte contre la
prostitution chargée d'organiser et de
coordonner l'action en faveur des
victimes
nous avons constaté que ces les mesures
de la loi sur ce pilier ont été déployés
progressivement mais de façon hétérogène
sur les territoires à la mise en place
des commissions de lutte contre la
prostitution
voilà c'est a été a été déployé mais
elle n'est pas encore achevé l'été en
tout cas pas encore achevé en décembre
puisqu'un quart des départements étaient
dépourvues d'une telle commission
les préfets les associations qui en qui
participent à ces commissions dans les
départements quelle ils ont mis en place
porte un regard positif sur ce
dispositif qui permet de mettre en
réseau les acteurs qui permet d'élaborer
parfois des orientations stratégiques
par exemple de mettre en place dans le
département des groupes de travail sur
la question de la prostitution des
mineurs mais certaines commissions sont
beaucoup moins active un tiers notamment
des commissions n'ont pas commencé à
examiner des parcours de sortie de la
prostitution et nous avons fait des
propositions pour rendre ce dispositif
plus souple
les parcours de santé la prostitution
enfin ne concerne qu'un nombre limité de
personnes au regard du public potentiel
environ 230 personnes ont bénéficié fin
juin 2019 et donc les personnes
accompagnées en parcours de sortie la
prostitution constitue une faible
proportion des personnes accompagnées
par les associations et me paraît
important qu'on puisse renforcer
là disponibles pour les personnes qui
souhaiteraient sortir de la prostitution
mais ne sont pas forcément concernés par
les parcours de sortie par exemple parce
que elles ne sont pas de nationalité
étrangère et relève plutôt du droit
comme un i dont nous avons créé que
puissent être créées en fonds d'action
sociale pour ces personnes alors
pourquoi en faible nombre de personnes
en parcours de sortir de la prostitution
déjà parce que c'est un dispositif qui
s'applique principalement pour des
personnes d'origine étrangère qui ne
sont pas éligibles au droit commun nous
avons constaté un taux de refus de non
négligeable près d'un cinquième des
dossiers présentés
souvent parce que les personnes ne
possèdent pas de document d'identité ou
parce qu'il ya des doutes sur une
éventuelle participation à des faits de
proxénétisme
et donc ça va ça explique ce taux de
refus non négligeable mais également
parce que il y a une importante
hétérogénéité entre des départements des
critères d'entrée dans un parcours de
sortie de la prostitution notamment au
regard du droit au séjour des
bénéficiaires il ya des critères
différencier certaines préfectures par
exemple n'accorde pas le bénéfice du
parcours pour des personnes qui sont sur
le fait d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français ou qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des doubles inné et donc pour
nous il ya vraiment un enjeu majeur à ce
que ces critères soient précisées soient
harmonisées au niveau national que ce
soit le critère de la mission ont droit
au séjour ont d'autres critères comme
celui de l'insertion professionnelle qui
est demandée ou de l'arrêt de la
prostitution et donc c'est parcours de
sorcier la prostitution et
l'organisation des commissions
départementales et chronophage sollicite
beaucoup les délégation départementale
aux droits des femmes et nous
recommandons que certaines puissent être
renforcée surtout en attendant les gros
département qu'on renforce leurs moyens
pour appliquer ce dispositif
donc je passe maintenant à la parole à
mon collègue cellulaire sur
l'accompagnement social et sanitaire des
personnes sorties de la prostitution et
je m'excuse je prévenais avoir excusé de
devoir m'éclipser dc dc 5 minutes
merci beaucoup à vous madame à vous
monsieur le président alors voilà pour
continuer sur les parcours de sortie
c'est extrêmement important c'est tout
ce qu'a dit amélie
c'est un énorme travail il ya de la
volonté de la bonne volonté dans
beaucoup de commissions et on sent que
les choses se mettent en place alors
regretté que ce soit pas plus rapide
mais enfin il ya quand même des choses
qui se mettent en place ce qu'on peu ce
qui nous a frappés c'est que c'est
tellement de temps et il ya tellement de
risques de refus des parcours que
certaines associations qui présentent
des dossiers n'ont finalement nous ont
avoué présenter les dossiers les plus
les plus à même d'être acceptée c'est à
dire qu'on va faire sortir de la
prostitution les gens qui sont déjà
quasiment sortis ou les plus les plus
proches de la sortie et les gens qui
sont très loin de la sortie de l'accès
au droit
et ben vont se retrouver encore plus en
situation de vulnérabilité et
d'isolement
donc il ya une harmonisation qui est
vraiment fondamental dans dans ces
commissions
et puis évidemment la sortie de
prostitution elle est compliquée pour
plusieurs raisons qui sont assez
évidentes mais qui concrètement bloc un
certain nombre de situations on a pu en
discuter avec les personnes concernées
c'est que comme elles sont obligées
d'arrêter leur activité pour bénéficier
du parcours ils se retrouvent sans
ressource et souvent rapidement sans
hébergement puisque l'hébergement est
souvent partagée et sert souvent à la
prostitution
donc il y a une il ya une difficulté
énorme de d'hébergement de ces personnes
il ya des associations sur le terrain
qui y travaillent mais évidemment
l'hébergement et 1 de manière générale
et notamment pour pour ces personnes
vulnérables extrême une situation
extrêmement difficile actuellement mais
pour autant on a vu des belles
initiatives dans certains endroits et il
ya des gens qu'on arrive à reloger
de manière séparée de l'aude leur ancien
logement pour pour pouvoir envisager un
projet d'insertion l'aphis donc l'aide
qui est octroyée pour cette sortie nous
a semblé tout à fait insuffisantes ses
330 euros
évidemment quand on le met en face des
gains
qui sont les gars de la prostitution de
l'activité prostitutionnelle de ces
personnes
ça n'a rien à voir donc on se retrouve
avec une difficulté d'hébergement une
difficulté financière mais qu'il est
très concrète qui suit vraiment le début
du parcours et des gens qui se
retrouvent assez démunis et tenter de
reprendre cette activité
pour ces raisons là et qui peuvent se
faire re capter bien évidemment par les
réseaux de prostitution très facilement
pour pour ces mêmes raisons
donc il ya un soutien financier il ya un
soutien en terme d'hébergement qui à
faire et qui est particulièrement
important et un soutien aux associations
qui s'en occupe
sur le terrain en plus de cet acte cet
aspect social pour pour dire un mot sur
l'aspect sanitaire
on a été frappé de voir que l'on
manquait vraiment cruellement de données
sur la question les dernières données
françaises indépendantes sur sur la
situation sanitaire des personnes
prostituées date de 2011 donc bien
évidemment ces données ont besoin d'être
actualisées puisque la sociologie n'est
pas la même les risques sanitaires ont
aussi bouger il faut évidemment assure
un suivi de ces données
et puis demio logique pour qu'on puisse
se rendre compte concrètement de ce que
ça implique évidemment quand on pense
prostitution on pense aux risques
d'infections sexuellement transmissibles
il ya souvent une assez bonne
connaissance de ces risques par les
personnes prostituées elles-mêmes mais
on a été assez frappé de voir qu'il y
avait de plus en plus de négociations
sur le non port du préservatif par les
clients qui phénomène assez récent
puisque de l'avis des personnes
prostituées elles-mêmes le client dix
ans aujourd'hui que c'est lui qui prend
là le risque si j'ose dire
eh bien il est en position de
négociation pour pour cela donc le
risque d'infections sexuellement
transmissibles aujourd'hui relativement
contrôlée mais avec ce phénomène plus un
phénomène plus général de relâchement
des comportements de prévention chez les
gens plus jeunes qui est qui est un
phénomène qui touche toute la société
on peut être
à juste titre un peu inquiet bien
évidemment il n'y a pas que cet aspect
infectiologie qu il ya aussi énormément
de conséquences sur le plan urgent
gynécologique sur le plan psychologique
bien évidemment les violences qu'elles
soient physiques mais aussi
psychologiques des clients des autres
personnes prostituées de l'environnement
globalement des proxénètes bien
évidemment
c'est un environnement globalement
hostile et globalement violent donc oui
sur le plan physique mais aussi beaucoup
c'est ce qui nous a frappés sur le
psychologique et c'est extrêmement lourd
et finalement une envisager une sortie
est un projet d'insertion dans ces
conditions là est d'autant plus
difficile
donc on a fait des recommandations sur
l'aspect sanitaire
il faut finalement identifié ces
situations le système de santé traite
bien quand on lui apporte le les
personnes nées il faut l il faut aller
vite
le système de santé est adaptée à la
prise en charge mais il faut encore
faut-il que ces personnes aillent
jusqu'au jusqu'au système de santé et là
il ya une coopération à faire entre
divers types d'associations celles qui
prennent en charge le parcours de sortie
celles qui prennent en charge les
risques sanitaires qui sont souvent pas
les mêmes et vous le savez ça a été dit
souvent opposés dans leur position par
rapport à cette loi mais c'est pas une
raison parce que sur le terrain on voit
des coopérations qui sont fructueuses
puisque chacun a sa spécialisation en
quelque sorte en tout cas pour le pour
le système de santé il faut que ces
personnes soient identifiés et qu'on
puisse amener le soin jusqu'à la
personne n'est pas la personne jusque
dans système de soins parce qu'elle
n'ira pas beaucoup n'iront pas pour
plein de raisons
alors que si on si on amène le l'hôpital
ou plus plus généralement le soin vers
ces personnes
ça peut fonctionner donc il faut des
personnels il faut qu'ils soient formés
et sensibilisés en tout cas parce que
dans le système de santé c'est une les
personnes prostituées c'est difficile à
voir c'est difficile à percevoir souvent
les gens ne le disent pas donc il ya des
risques particuliers qui sont pas
toujours mises en évidence et puis il
faut du temps dédié surtout puisque si
ces deux là les verts et ben il faut
bien qu'ils aient du temps médical du
temps paramédical pour aller vers ces
personnes en mobilité et
et les prendre en charge je finirai sur
le soutien aux associations qui me
paraît parfaitement plus que nécessaire
indispensable si on veut que ça
fonctionne c'est sont les associations
qui sont sur le terrain
encore une fois qu'elles soient pour ou
contre cette loi et le soutient
d'ailleurs financier à ces associations
il soutient même plus globale politique
à ces associations ne doit pas être fait
en fonction de leurs positions par
rapport à la loi en fonction du travail
effectivement réalisées sur le terrain
et des coopérations qui peuvent être
mises en place je vais donner la parole
à catherine pourre merci monsieur
loulergue donc nous allons la
présentation était à trois voix donc
pour ce rapport de mission et donc c'est
à madame la magistrate catherine gay que
je cède la parole bien volontiers merci
à vous monsieur merci beaucoup madame la
présidente dont je partage le plaisir
exprimé par amélie piccinelli de
participer à cette table ronde
alors je vais évoquer la un peu plus
particulièrement les la question des
réseaux sociaux et de la prostitution
des mineurs alors comme vous comme ça a
été dit
nous nous sommes heurtés à une absence
de statistiques quantitatives fiables
sûrs s'agissant du phénomène
prostitutionnel malgré des rapports qui
préconise l évaluation de la
prostitution depuis 2011
il ya eu de rapports geoffroy il ya eu
le rapport de l'igas en 2012 il ya eu un
rapport et des déclarations de monsieur
toubon
quelque temps après les statistiques
policières ou judiciaires dont nous
disposons reflète l'activité des
services de police et de gendarmerie
mais elles sont loin de refléter
l'ampleur de la prostitution sur notre
territoire
les informations et les évolutions plus
générale relève donc des sondages d'
analyse des rapports d'être des
associations spécialisées
mais quelles que soient leurs qualités
certaines
elle reste ça reste des données restent
indicative et ne peuvent eux ne sont pas
aujourd'hui stabilisé selon une étude de
pro cost en 2015 le nombre des personnes
prostituées en france était évalué à 37
milles
c'était une moyenne entre une évaluation
une fourchette basse de 30000 à une
fourchette haute de 44 mille personnes
ça a été dit on constate aujourd'hui un
déclin de la prostitution sur la voie
publique sur la voie publique les
victimes prostituées sont souvent
d'origine étrangère et dans une
prostitution qui est structuré dans des
réseaux par des réseaux exploités
souvent par des compatriotes selon look
très qui est représentée aujourd'hui
dont je vais pas trop me
mais tendre et amélie a donné quelques
chiffres la part des victimes
identifiées sur la voie publique aurait
fortement diminué en trois ans en 2016
des à 54% et en 2018 à 38%
parallèlement on note une nette
progression de l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux qui sur cette période faste de
34 à 49 %
une étude sitel de mai 2015
mentionnez déjà que 62% de la
prostitution passer par internet en 2018
sur les 69 réseau démantelé par les
services de post it de police et de
gendarmerie
trente trois concernaient une
prostitution dite logé entre 2015 et
2018 les codes les condamnations
prononcées en france pour proxénétisme
aggravé avec mise en contact par un
réseau de communications étaient
s'agissant d'une victime majeure 2015 73
2016 43 2017 51 2018 72 s'agissant d'une
victime mineure
les chiffres étaient de 2 2 en 2015 de 3
en 2016 de 3 en 2010 est et de 1 en 2018
à eux seuls ces chiffres attestent nous
semble-t-il du décalage qu'il peut y
avoir entre les statistiques et les
poursuites et l'ampleur du phénomène
prostitutionnel ce constat doit
impérativement contraindre les pouvoirs
publics à renforcer les moyens des
services de police et de gendarmerie
pour lutter contre le proxénétisme et la
traite via notamment les réseaux sociaux
et internet
il est nous avons donc préconisé
évidemment ça a été dit par ça a déjà
été dit un accroissement des moyens
humains et numérique
notamment toutes les investigations en
effet convergent pour affirmer que
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux et des
plateformes d'annonce en ligne associée
à la généralisation des nouvelles
technologies les tablettes les ordis les
téléphones etc tout ce qui est connecté
facilite le phénomène prostitutionnel de
même le téléphone portable est un outil
d'emprise extraordinaire puisqu'il
assure une disponibilité ininterrompue
des victimes et une relation à distance
permanente entre le recruteur le
proxénète et le client cela est
particulièrement vrai s'agissant de la
prostitution des mineurs qui sont
parfois enfin qui ont souvent leur
téléphone tout le monde connaît le tueur
sur leur portable par les mineurs et les
mineurs qui sont qui se retrouvent
parfois bien peu armés pour se préserver
des effets pervers de ce monde virtuel
ce qui accroît leur vu leur
vulnérabilité
les réseaux sociaux que nous connaissons
pas et ce bouquin sur gran twitter
snapshot tictoc maintenant favorise le
repérage et le recrutement d'adolescents
en vue de leur exploitation via la
publication des annonces sur des
plateformes d'échangés des sites dédiés
à l'escorting c'est réseau facilite la
mise en relation avec des clients par
des messageries instantanées de groupe
ou la diffusion d'image ou de vidéos
intimes
or les textes qui incrimine le
proxénétisme et la jurisprudence
actuelle ne permettent pas d'assimiler
ces comportements prostitutionnel
virtuel à de la prostitution
en l'absence de relation physique avec
le client la loi en effet ne donne pas
de définition de la prostitution
question doit-elle le faire la cour de
cassation a défini la prostitution comme
le fait de se traiter moyennement
moyennant une rémunération à des
contacts physiques de quelque nature
qu'il soit pour satisfaire les besoins
sexuels d'autrui cette définition ne
paraît pas plus adapté
à l'évolution des pratiques
prostitutionnel et au développement de
nouvelles technologies des nouvelles
technologies nous sommes nous avons posé
la question d'une définissent pas les
seuls à l association clip en fait les
unes novembre voilà une définition
légale la question d'une définition
légale de la prostitution faisant
apparaître toute forme de
marchandisation du corps et
d'exploitation sexuelle pourrait
peut-être être envisagée tout cas il ya
un débat là-dessus ce qui permettrait de
faciliter l'information peut-être sur la
réalité de la faute de la de la
prostitution de banaliser toutes les
attitudes prostitutionnel notamment
s'agissant pour nous faire pour les
jeunes
et puis de faciliter le travail des
professionnels les dispositif de
signalement des sites facilite le
proxénétisme et la traite des êtres
humains qui il est qui qui voilà qui
sont aujourd'hui apparaissent
aujourd'hui peu efficace alors sur ce
point la mission a noté que la rédaction
initiale de l'article 1er de la loi du
13 avril permettait à l'autorité
administrative de demander aux
fournisseurs d'accès de bloquer l'accès
aux sites utilisés par les réseaux de
prostitution et 7,7 rédaction initiale
n'a pas été retenue la rédaction finale
se contente d'exiger des sites qui le
met en place un dispositif de
signalement de contenus illicites dont
sans lequel on peut enfin qui paraît
perfectible il existe
amélie on a parlé de dispositifs pour
les internautes et les citoyens en
france deux dispositifs principaux de
signalements de contenus en ligne du
site
la plateforme pharos qui existe depuis
2009 et la plateforme points de contacts
qu'on a quand même aussi nous identifier
mais
il semble que enfin il nous semble que
ces dispositifs en ligne de de
signalement des contenus en ligne des
sites ne sont pas assez connus du public
ni des associations qui pourtant
pourraient être susceptibles de
transmettre des informations
exploitables et ces dispositifs sont
prioritairement alimenté par les
services d' enquête
bon après on le comprend parce qu'il ya
aussi une question de moyens bon voilà
là la mission a donc préconisé le
renforcement des partenariats des
directions et des services dédiés à la
lutte contre le cyber proxénétisme avec
les sites hébergeurs de forums ou de
petites annonces pour signaler des
contenus illicites liés au proxénétisme
et à la traite des êtres humains
la traite des êtres humains elle
rappelle elle souligne que dans le cadre
de la mise en oeuvre de la loi du 13
avril 2016 et du comité de suivi du
cinquième plan de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
un groupe de travail pluridisciplinaire
chargée d'identifier les moyens de
lutter contre le cyber proxénétisme
devaient être créés et que ce groupe de
travail n'a pas vu le jour et l'afrique
la mission avait donc préconisé son
installation et le lancement d'une
mission dédiée à la pro à cette
problématique là le
leur
la mission a souligné le rôle majeur
joué par les associations dans la
prévention et l'accompagnement des
personnes qui se prostituent si compris
sur internet
les associations ont développé des
maraudes ont développé des unes présente
une présence éducative sur le net
néanmoins il convient que les dotations
qui leur sont allouées prennent en
compte ce nouveau mode d'accompagnement
des victimes qui est particulièrement
chronophage mais très efficace et
complémentaire de ce qui peut se faire
par ailleurs l'évocation de cette
prostitution par les réseaux sociaux et
internet nous conduit naturellement à
évoquer la prostitution inquiétante des
mineurs la loi du 13 avril 2016 a bien
sûr vocation à s'appliquer à toutes les
victimes qu'elle soit mineure comme
majeur néanmoins elle ne refaire
expressément à l'art prostitution des
mineurs que par le biais des articles 18
et 19 et d'articles en deux les articles
18 et 19 sont relatifs aux actions
d'information dans les établissements
scolaires consacré aux réalités de la
prostitution aux dangers d'une
marchandisation du corps et à la
promotion des relations égalitaires
entre les femmes et les hommes
tout est dit l'article 22 de la loi
énumère
dans les bilans attendu de cette loi
celui de l'évolution de la situation et
du repérage et de la prise en charge des
mineurs et des étudiants se livrant à la
prostitution la prostitution des mineurs
en france elle n'est pas nouvelle
une noix de du 11 avril 2009 108 était
déjà venu l'encadré à une période à une
époque où elle était perçue comme
grandissante la prostitution des mineurs
et les l'interdiction de la prostitution
des mineurs la prostitution des mineurs
est consacrée par la loi du 4 mars 2002
relative à l'autorité parentale dont
l'article 13 dispose que la prostitution
des mineurs est interdite sur tout le
territoire de la république et que tout
mineur qui se prostituent est réputé en
danger et relève de la protection et de
l'assistance éducative
cette interdiction n'a pas éteint le
phénomène loin de l'art et la mission a
constaté à que constater que ce principe
était parfois même un peu trop souvent
pour nous ignoré du grand public voire
de certains professionnels
il existe un écart très important entre
les statistiques sur la prostitution des
mineurs issus des services de police et
des procédures judiciaires qui sont
relatives à des affaires traitées est
terminée bien évidemment et les
estimations faites par les associations
les associations spécialisées évalue à
partir de leurs maraudes et d accueil et
de leur accueil la proportion de mineurs
dans leur file active à 25 ou 30 % soit
de 6000 à 10 mille mineurs en situation
de prostitution
la mission n'a pas été en mesure
d'objectiver
ce chiffre néanmoins bien vous avez
compris pourquoi puisqu'on n'a pas de
statistiques d'évaluation plus plus plus
fiable en 2017
look très comptabilisait 129 victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle et 147 en 2018
et la proportion des victimes mineures
augmente d'année en année puisque 10% 18
6 % en 2016 elle représente de 10 6% en
2007 et représente 15% du total des
victimes en 2018
à la même époque les magistrats en
charge des cours d'appel de paris évalué
à au minimum 130 au maximum de 160 le
nombre des mineurs victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle sur leur ressort
et c'est de marseille à 250
vous voyez là que le total de ces
chiffres sur deux villes dépassent très
largement à eux seuls les chiffres de
look très est par ailleurs ces chiffres
ne reflètent qu'une partie que la partie
visible et donc partielle du phénomène
puisque dans ces chiffres on ne prend
pas en compte les mineurs en situation
d'errance d'isolement ceux qui sont
cachés derrière les réseaux sociaux est
ni ce qu'ils sont suivis dans le cadre
de la prévention ou de la protection
administrative donc l'augmentation
inquiétante et non maîtrisée de la
prostitution des mineurs justifie d'en
renforcer la place l'évaluation et de
prières prioriser les actions destinées
à la prévenir âmes selon la mission est
bon on est et on s'était pas trop
peut-être trompé la nomination récente
du secrétaire d'état à la protection de
l'enfance pouvait permettre d'inscrire
cette problématique dans le champ
interministériel de la protection de
l'enfance qui paraissait devoir être le
sien
et la présence de madame la procureure
générale catherine champrenault
à cette table ronde atteste du chemin
par contre la prostitution des mineurs
elle est protéiforme et elle s'exerce
dans des lieux différents la rue aux
abords des gares via les réseaux sociaux
les sites d'annoncés parfois aux
alentours des établissements de la
protection de l'enfance voir au sein des
établissements de la protection de
l'enfance
l'activité s'exerce dans des lieux très
différents hôtels bars boîtes de nuit
appartement parfois établissements
scolaires les adolescents qui se
prostituent sont principalement
majoritairement des filles de
nationalité française
exception faite pour s'agissant des
ménages est pas mais je développerai pas
ce point si le phénomène de proximité de
proxénétisme dit de cité est en voie de
progression
il est dépassé les jeux les mineurs ou
les jeunes majeurs qui sont en danger de
prostitution ne sont plus toutes issues
des quartiers défavorisés des banlieues
dans des grandes agglomérations
il ya une diffusion enfin voilà c'est
bien au delà de cela c'est les victimes
sont âgées de 14 à 23 ans et des
attitudes prostitutionnel précoces sont
signalés dans les établissements
scolaires dès la 5eme donc 12 13 ans les
proxénètes ont entre 17 et 25 ans ils
sont souvent connus des services
d'enquêté notamment pour des affaires de
trafic de stupéfiants ils sont souvent
issus des mêmes territoires que leur
victime et on observe une grande
mobilité dans les andes an dans ses
réseaux d échange de victimes entre
réseaux on observe une similitude entre
les réseaux de trafic de stupéfiants et
ceux de l'exploitation sexuelle les
mineurs victimes de prostitution sont
majoritairement décrit comme fragilisé
très fragilisé psychologiquement par un
parcours de vie émaillée de violences en
quête d'affection de reconnaissance de
valorisation elles sont souvent
déscolarisés souvent fugueuse et souvent
sans encadrement familial suffisant
certains certaines en errance recours à
une prostituée
sion de subsistance occasionnels
échangeons des prestations sexuelles
contre un logement de la nourriture et
parfois de la drogue la précarité
économique et la facilité apparente de
se procurer très vite de l'argent pour
satisfaire des besoins de consommation
parfois dispendieux explique aussi ce
glissement vers la prostitution les
phénomènes de loverboy 2000 stone age
décrit depuis plusieurs années sont
aujourd'hui des stratégies de
recrutement largement répandue de
victimes très vulnérable facilement sous
emprise psychologique ou affective
facilement appâtés par l'intérêt qu'il
aurait porté ou le cadeau qui leur sont
faits avant d'être soumise à des
violences voire des séquestrations de
même le coup on a souvent entendu parler
du consentement revendiquée par la
victime elle-même ou de son attachement
affiché pour son agresseur c'est ces
constats sont déplorés et sont faits par
les professionnels dans quêtes et les
professionnels de la protection de
l'enfance qui se déclare impuissant face
à de tels un tel positionnement pour
diligenter des procédures et protéger
les victimes
là se pose la question de la formation
des professionnels et de la prise en
compte de la qualité de victime dans ces
procédures la nature aussi de ces
procédures est ce que c'est des sauriens
de verre d d d d enquête de traite ou
victimes de violences simplement et des
droits qui peuvent être être attaché à
ces victimes mineures de prostitution ou
de traite la prise en charge des mineurs
en danger de prostitution alors je vais
plutôt parler des trains qui n'arrivent
pas alors que de tout ce qui se fait de
bien mais on est là pour avancer
alors le juge des enfants est
généralement toujours saisi parce que la
protection administratives s'avèrent
insuffisantes au regard de la gravité du
danger du profil des mineurs est souvent
de leur opposition aux mesures de
protection
il convient de souligner l'importance
des rôles des cris pfff les cellule de
recueil des informations préoccupantes
créé que tu une instance départementale
fondamentale créé par la loi de 2007
interface avec tous les services
départementaux les juridictions
l'éducation nationale les réseaux
associatifs de santé la la
le fonctionnement dans transmise au
stade en transversalité partenariale est
tout à fait important et fondamental
dans le traitement de cette
problématique
comme amélie l'a fait remarquer tout à
l'heure s'agissant de des sites pharos
nous avions remarqué que les items
prostitution ou risque de prostitution
ne figurait pas sur les fiches renseigné
par les cryptes de la même façon et
c'était la même chose sur le site le 119
voilà donc nous avions fait une
recommandation d'harmoniser les critères
d'identification des critères des
situations de danger encouru par les
mineurs entre toutes les grippes
qu'elles aient toutes les mêmes critères
et le 119 pour que
il convient de souligner l'importance de
la transmission par les départements de
toutes les données anonymisées
allô allô allô des pays hôtes
observatoires départementaux de la
protection de l'enfance ou à l'office
national de protection de l'enfance afin
de pouvoir suivre l'évolution de
l'enfance en danger et d'ajuster la
politique de la protection de l'enfance
il faut souligner l'efficacité du
partenariat entre les représentants des
services les deux sociaux de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et l'autorité
judiciaire
les protocoles tels que ceux qui ont été
initiées par le parquet général de paris
le parquet général d'aix-en-provence et
dans certains tribunaux pour destinée à
harmoniser à faciliter la prise en
charge des mineurs et des majeurs en
danger de prostitution doivent être
devrait être développé dans tous les
départements confrontés à une
problématique prostitutionnel importante
il faut souligner l'inexistence en
france d'établissement spécialisé dans
la prise en charge des mineurs en danger
de prostitution tous les professionnels
le déplorent les mineurs donc en danger
de prostitution sont orientés vers des
dispositifs de droit commun de la
protection de l'enfance dont les limites
sont unanimement souligné pourquoi
nombre de places insuffisante dans les
établissements absence de formation des
personnels qu'ils déplorent eux mêmes
c'est pas c'est pas voilà et de
pluridisciplinarité dans les équipes
éducatives notamment dans la prise en
charge de l'état psychique et physique
de ces mineurs
or la spécialisation et la
pluridisciplinarité des équipes
éducatives conditionne la réussite d'une
prise en charge qui s'avère extrêmement
complexe on note une insuffisance des
structures d'accueil éloignées qui
permette qui devrait permettre de
soustraire les victimes à l'emprise de
leurs réseaux et de leur assurer une
protection sur ce point il nous était
apparu que les dispositifs de type accès
ou des dispositifs d'accueil coordonnées
expérimenté à paris et coordonnée par
l'ami prof depuis 2016 pour les victimes
de traite pourrait être dupliquée en
faveur
2 de toutes les pour les victimes
mineures de toutes formes d'exploitation
sexuelle et pas forcément réservé
uniquement aux situations de traite de
la même façon le pilotage d'un réseau de
10 d'un dispositif d'hébergement nous
paraissait pouvoir être envisagée pour
diversifier les modes d'accueil
collectif éclaté individualisé famille
d'accueil et offrir des séjours de
rupture
enfin une attention particulière nous
paraissait comme c'est fait dans
certains tirs près du territoire et ça
marche bien être
portez à l'évaluation des situations de
fugue qui sont très fréquentes chez les
mineurs en danger de prostitution et les
protocoles de gestion de fugue qui ont
été déclarées déployés dans certains
territoires entre les services de police
les services de l'autorité l'autorité
judiciaire et les services de protection
de l'enfance doivent être encouragés
alors s'agissant de la prostitution
étudiante
c'est une réalité qui n'est pas
suffisamment repéré n'est évaluée je
pense que je vais pas vous et de vous
étonner la dgesip évaluer à partir
d'éléments fournis par l'amicale du nid
et les chefs de service universitaire de
médecine préventive
le pourcentage de l'à propos de la
population étudiante reconnaissant avoir
procédé à des actes sexuels en échange
d'argent de biens ou davantage d'hiver à
3% de près de 3% et en 2019
le nombre d'étudiants inscrits dans
l'enseignement supérieur était de 2
millions 7 dont 3 % de 2007 selon alors
ces chiffres rejoignent je vais vite à
une étude de l'observatoire et a très
peu d'études sur cette problématique
une étude de l'observatoire de la vie
étudiante de 2016 qui est évalué à 1 9%
les étudiants qui avaient été confrontés
qu'avait été en situation
prostitutionnel souvent pour sortir
d'une situation financière difficile ou
améliorer le quotidien j'ouvre une
parenthèse sur la période de crise
sanitaire que nous connaissons et
l'après que la précarisation des publics
jeunes et des risques accrus
voilà pour eux et en 2019
l'université un nouveau diagnostic de
réalisée par l'université de grenoble en
relation avec l'amicale du nid et la
ddcs évaluer ce pour un pourcentage une
évolué une une évolution de la
prostitution des mineurs par rapport à 1
au même diagnostic réalisé trois ans
plus tôt on passait de 4 à 7%
donc si aujourd'hui cette problématique
n'apparaît pas particulièrement
prioritaires en termes de risque on note
quand même surtout sur le terrain dans
l'est dans les universités une volonté
de sensibilisation des professionnels et
des étudiants
une mobilisation des crous des services
universitaires de santé et des
associations étudiantes qui développe
des actions de sensibilisation et des
campagnes d'information la réalité donc
s'agissant delà de la prostitution
étudiante nous préconisions une
évaluation de sa réalité puisqu'on sait
qu'elle existe une évaluation qui serait
piloté par la direction générale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de
l'insertion professionnelle et qui
serait un préalable nécessaire pour
prévenir ce phénomène et garantir aux
étudiants des conditions de vie et de
santé adaptés à la réussite de leurs
études
je vais bientôt conclure je dirais pour
conclure que 50% des personnes qui se
prostituent auraient été victimes de
violences sexuelles dans l'enfance bien
qu'on ait santec en 2017
vingt-trois mille mineurs ont été
victimes de violences sexuelles dont
treize mille enfants de moins de 13 ans
ce constat et les difficultés que nous
avons énoncé et développer relatives à
la prise en charge des mineurs en danger
prostitution doivent contraindre les
pouvoirs publics à développer la
prévention le plus tôt possible voire
l'aide à la parentalité la formation des
enseignants des professionnels
la protection de l'enfance des services
d'enquêté des magistrats est la pierre
angulaire
elle doit être renforcée elle existe un
il ya des choses plein de choses qui se
font un
mais elle doit être renforcé et
développé aujourd'hui les associations
spécialisées ne peuvent pas à elles
seules couvrir l'intégralité des besoins
de formation
ou alors faut vraiment vraiment renforcé
considérablement leurs moyens tous les
professionnels et les experts rencontrés
ont souligné l'importance de la
formation des enseignants et des
personnels des services sociaux et de
santé scolaire pour mettre en place une
politique de prévention et assurer la
protection des élèves
la formation des personnels de
l'éducation nationale est un préalable
nécessaire aux actions de prévention
l'article 18 de la loi du 13 avril 2016
ne semble avoir eu pour l'instant qu'une
portée limitée et aucune circulaire
relative à la mise en oeuvre à cette
analyse honnête de cet article 18
et cette politique de formation n'étant
tna n'a été diffusée
ce constat illustre l'absence de portage
politique dont a souffert la mise en
oeuvre de cette loi dont l'ambition
première pourtant était d'élever la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
au rang d'une véritable politique
interministérielle la dynamique
enclenchée après l'adoption de la loi
s'est rapidement essoufflé la continuité
du comité de suivi de la mise en oeuvre
de cette loi qui devait regrouper les
ministères et les secteurs et les
secteurs les acteurs du secteur
associatif en vue de préparer des
décrets et des circulaires cette
commission qui a été réuni dès le 14
juin par la ministre de l'enfance des
familles des droits des femmes n'a pas
été assuré aucune communication
gouvernementale n'a été déployée en
direction du grand public
donc voilà les femmes victimes de
prostitution et les mineurs en danger de
prostitution bon alors ça je n'engage
que moi on
on dirait était un peu oublié oublié
alors même que la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes s'est
renforcée merci beaucoup pour cette très
belle présentation à trois voix est
assez précise et qui dresse un tableau
assez éloquente de la situation actuelle
et de l'aggravation de la situation
malgré une loi qui était utile et
importante
je vais immédiatement donné la parole à
madame elvira righi qui est commissaire
de police chef de l'office central pour
la répression de la traite des êtres
humains à la direction centrale de la
police judiciaire pour nous présenter le
bilan de l'application de la loi
vu du côté du ministère de l'intérieur à
vous madame merci madame la présidente
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames
messieurs
créé en 1958
l'office central pour la répression de
la traite des êtres humains que l'on
appelle aux crêtes appartient à la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire dont le coeur de métier est
la lutte contre la criminalité organisée
et le grand banditisme en mon service
dispose d'une compétence nationale il se
concentre sur la traite des êtres
humains à vocations sexuelle et sa
mission est double tout d'abord une
mission opérationnelle qui est celle de
mener des enquêtes complexes et élaborer
d'ampleur nationale ou internationale
afin de démanteler des réseaux de traite
des êtres humains de grande envergure à
l'aide de techniques spéciales denquête
tels que la géolocalisation la pose de
balises les enquêtes sous pseudonyme et
d'autre
d'autre part une mission stratégique qui
est celle de concentrer pour le
ministère de l'intérieur l'intégralité
des données sur la thématique de la
traite à vocation sexuelle et du
proxénétisme en ce sens ces données que
vous avez les uns et les autres utiliser
j'ai la chance d'avoir plus les
actualiser un et d'avoir notamment les
données de 2020 je crois que celles qui
ont été cités s'arrêter en 2018 les
tendances que vous avez évoqué
simplement se confirme s'accélère à
vitesse grand v j'y reviendrai ça donne
à mon office une vision d'ensemble du
phénomène de son évolution et nous
permet de détecter de nouvelles
tendances et d'en aviser des services
territoriaux afin que les méthodes d
enquête s'adapte à ces changements
parfois extrêmement rapide
c'est grâce à cette double mission l'une
purement opérationnel l'autre
stratégique qui m'est permis aujourd'hui
de vous donner un bilan non seulement
documenté et chiffré mais également
concret nourrit d'éléments issus du
terrain de l'application de la loi
d'avril 2016
alors je précise que vu le temps qui
m'est imparti j'ai beaucoup coupé mon
propos et notamment tout ce qui est
évoqué sur la prostitution des mineurs
est également extrêmement documenté par
parle aux crêtes je n'y reviendrai pas
aujourd'hui je parle de la loi en
général et si ce sujet me paraît
absolument essentiel et madame
champrenault c'est que notre
investissement dans ce dans ce groupe de
travail j'ai une autre préoccupation qui
est aussi celle qui n'occulte pas la
persistance des réseaux étrangers
extrêmement structurée extrêmement
organisés et plongeant de nombreuses
femmes dans une misère absolue et ce
phénomène persistant j'articule raymond
propos autour de quatre éléments
principaux de la loi qui ont eu un
impact sur l'activité quotidienne des
forces de l'ordre dans leur lutte contre
le système prostitutionnel
alors tout d'abord la pénalisation de
l'achat d'actes sexuels ou pénalisation
du client
c'est une mission qui est accompli par
les services de police et de gendarmerie
du quotidien qui travaille sur la voie
publique principalement et qui est donc
tout à fait dépendante de la politique
de sécurité publique locale
ce qui fait que nous avons des chiffres
extrêmement variées si dans vos
questions vous souhaitez qu'on rentre
dans les détails par région par exemple
je pourrais le faire mais deux du nombre
de verbalisations d'individus dix
clients de d'actes sexuels
donc le nombre de verbalisations
d'individus ayant sollicité ou accepté
des relations sexuelles avec une
personne se livrant à la prostitution
s'est avéré stable de 2017 à 2020 sur
cette période
on estime à une moyenne de 1300
individus qui ont été verbalisés par an
dans ces circonstances l'article 130 de
tir et 11 du code pénal prévoit une
contravention comme ça a été dit de 1500
euros et 3750 euros en cas de récidive
on constate fort logiquement une chute
significative du nombre de personnes
verbalisées en 2020 c'est évidemment lié
à la pandémie de lakovic 19 donc une
chute de 45% de ces verbalisations en
2020 cette chute n'est cependant pas
inquiet tant en termes de mobilisation
policière dans le domaine puisque en
2021 les verbalisations ce reparti à la
hausse avec un mois de mars record
depuis la création de cette infraction
par la loi de 2016 à savoir 178 de
verbalisation pour le seul mois de mars
au-delà de ces chiffres qui permettent
d'objectiver l'application de la loi de
2016 il convient de souligner que cette
pénalisation est un levier pour les
enquêteurs dans le domaine du
proxénétisme de la traite
il est en effet plus facile quand c'est
nécessaire d'entrer en contact avec
l'auteur de cette infraction est de
recueillir son témoignage étayé
permettant de mettre au jour des
éléments d'enquêté comme un numéro de
téléphone du proxénète
le tarif exigé les conditions de la
prestation sexuelle et de mieux
comprendre les auteurs du réseau de
proxénétisme en revanche cette
pénalisation a pu avoir un effet négatif
sur le mode opératoire des réseaux qui
exploitent les victimes en les acheteurs
les consommateurs d'actes sexuels ne
souhaitant pas être verbalisés les
malfaiteurs se sont adaptés à cette
demande et leur propose une mise en
relation avec la muse victime
prostituées soit en ligne soit par
téléphone
l'acte sexuel ensuite lieu en hôtel ou
en appartement c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prostitution loger dans notre jargon
rendant la verbalisation bien plus
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
tant et si bien que l'effet recherché
par la loi à savoir la baisse de la
consommation d'actes sexuels tarifés n'a
sans doute pas été atteint mais qu'on
assiste plutôt un déplacement des
victimes prostituées ou trafiqué de
l'espace public vers l'espace numérique
et l'espace privé bien entendu la loi
n'est pas la seule
responsable de cette de cette tendance
un ça va de soi le deuxième point de la
loi qui a fortement impacté l'activité
des services de police et de gendarmerie
c'est la suppression du délit de
racolage elle est prévue par l'article
15 de la loi d'avril 2016
la suppression du délit de racolage et
bien entendu le corollaire de la
pénalisation du client et vient
consacrer le changement total de
paradigme endroits comme en fait
concernant la perception française du
phénomène prostitutionnel la prostituée
est désormais une victime en toutes
circonstances et elle est victime
à double titre elle est victime de son
éventuel proxénète d'une part mais elle
est également victime du client et du
consommateur elle ne peut en aucun cas
et quel que soit son éventuelle attitude
proactive est remise en cause par un
service de police
il est intéressant de prendre conscience
qu'il s'agit là pour les services
enquêteurs traitant de la question du
proxénétisme d'une sorte de révolution
copernicienne
si le précédent système est encore ancré
dans le discours de certains enquêteurs
à l'ancienne et vous le rappeliez tout à
l'heure madame on sent toutefois que le
changement culturel se fait et s'intègre
en profondeur petit à petit il convient
toutefois de souligner que les policiers
se voient en conséquence techniquement
privé depuis 2016 et ça a été rappelée
d'un outil qui est l'audition dans le
cadre de d'une garde à vue d'une
personne se livrant à la prostitution ça
n'est évidemment plus possible dès lors
seule une audition sous la forme de
témoignage de dépositions de victimes
est envisageable ne permettant pas
l'enquêteur de contraindre la victime à
rester si elle souhaite partir il se
trouve que ces auditions sont
particulièrement précieuse pour donner
des éléments de preuve permettant de
confondre les mises en cause et les
mettre hors d'état de nuire
c'est à dire les membres des réseaux de
traite et de proxénétisme et garantir
leur condamnation
or les en compte les enquêteurs on a
parlé du soi-disant consentement ou de
l'emprise qu'il peut y avoir sur les
victimes
les enquêteurs constatent
quotidiennement que les victimes sont
souvent sous l'emprise de leurs
proxénètes se disant
se croyant consentante à la prostitution
et elle accepte peu de témoigner dans le
cadre d'une simple audition de victimes
ça c'est un constat extrêmement
partagées et ça n'est pas parce qu'on
fait + d'enquêté qu'on est plus
productif que nos témoignages sont de
meilleure qualité je pense que ces
chiffres ne sont pas ne sont pas parlant
sur ce sur ce sujet donc ces victimes
cherchent souvent arrivé au strict
minimum le temps de l'audition afin de
pouvoir s'en aller au plus vite ce qui
peut évidemment gêné l'enquète convient
toutefois de tempérer l'impact négatif
de l'impossibilité de procéder à une
audition dans le cadre d'une garde à vue
en effet et c'est le troisième point de
la loi qui change vraiment de manière de
travailler
les nouveaux droits accordés aux
victimes par la loi de 2016 et notamment
le droit au séjour
si elle porte plainte ou celle témoigne
dans le cadre d'une enquête de
proxénétisme ou de traite constitue un
levier important pour l'enquêteur qui
doit pouvoir s'en servir pour créer des
relations de confiance avec la victime
lui permettant de la protéger et de
recueillir des éléments d'audition
intéressant donc suite à la loi de 2016
le cred s'est attaché à créer un procès
verbal type d'audition de victimes de
traite ou de proxénétisme qui prévoit
que l'enquêteur avant d'entendre la
victime sur le fond de la sphère est de
recueillir son témoignage lui notifie
l'ensemble de ses droits et l'invitent à
les exercer
parmi ces droits figure notamment si la
victime accepte de témoigner ou de
porter plainte
la possibilité d'obtenir une carte de
séjour vie privée vie familiale
permettant l'exercice d'une activité
professionnelle
il est également proposé à la victime de
rencontrer une association spécialisée
qui peut la mettre à l'abri à l'issue de
l'audition et l'assister dans ses
démarches de sortie du parcours
prostitutionnel
ce nouveau procès verbal a été diffusé à
l'ensemble des services territoriaux de
la police judiciaire et les prévu de
l'intégrer aux logiciels de rédaction
des procédures de la police nationale
afin d'être accessible à tout policier
de terrain bien évidemment l'exercice de
ces droits suppose une articulation fine
entre les associations qui prennent le
relais à l'issue de l'audition et les
services enquêteurs
apprendre à agir de concert n'est pas
forcément simple
nos cultures de travailler nos approches
étant nécessairement différente
et pourtant bien complémentaires des
partenariats de qualité se construisent
c'est ainsi que début mars par exemple
début mars 2021 à l'occasion d'une et
mentalement par mon office d'un réseau
international de traite et à l'occasion
donc de l'interpellation d'une quinzaine
d'individus dans quatre pays différents
mon office a pu mobiliser grâce à
l'association à lc dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure le dispositif national
d'accueil et de protection des victimes
de traite
une quarantaine de victimes libérez
momentanément du joug de leurs
proxénètes répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire national se sont ainsi vu
offrir la possibilité d'être mise en
relation avec une association
spécialisée
si toutes n'ont pas accepté une petite
dizaine toutefois en saisit cette
opportunité
ces partenariats de terrain construit
sur la base une confiance mutuelle se
solidifie et s'affine au fil des retours
d'expérience pour vous donner un exemple
assez parlants suite à cette opération
d'envergure de mars 2021 a été évoquée
la plus value que pourrait apporter une
association à intervenir en amont de
l'audition plutôt que de prendre le
relais à l'issue afin de mettre la
victime plus en confiance pour témoigner
d'une part et de multiplier les chances
qu'elle accepte effectivement l'aide de
l'association pour une sortie du
parcours prostitutionnel d'autre part
toutefois et ça va être là le coeur de
mon de mon propos pour que ces droits
puissent être effectivement notifié pour
que ces droits puissent être
effectivement exercées il convient avant
toute chose de passer par le basique
c'est à dire de trouver les victimes ans
c'est à dire de les identifier et
d'avoir accès à l or c'est évidemment là
que réside aujourd'hui le défi majeur de
l'accompagnement des victimes du système
prostitutionnel la prostitution se fait
aujourd'hui et les chiffres de mon
office sont donc actualisé en 2020 à je
vous parle de 2020 la prostitution se
fait aujourd'hui à plus de 90% en hôtel
ou en appartement alors évidemment vous
l'avez tous souligné ce sont les
statistiques policières donc c'est le
reflet de notre activité dans nos dans
nos procédures c'est un parfait ça n'est
pas un une image sociétale de l'ampleur
du phénomène qui est certainement
beaucoup plus gros numériquement que ce
que l'on perçoit nous néanmoins les
tendances les pourcentages doivent peu
ou prou correspondre à la halle à la
réalité et donc au moment où la loi
était adoptée en été vous l'évoquez tout
à l'heure à 53 54% de la prostitution
qui se faisait sur la voie publique
on a vu ce pourcentage diminue et au fil
des ans pour atteindre aujourd'hui
seulement 9%
évidemment le coc vide a accéléré cette
tendance qui était déjà déjà enclenché
cela rend l'accès aux victimes et leur
protection bien plus complexe car leur
activité est rendue quasiment invisible
en jeu souligne d'ailleurs que cette
tendance à la prostitution via internet
et donc la pause prostitution loger ne
concerne peut alors concerne bien sûr
les mineurs vous l'avez évoqué mais il
ne concerne pas du tout exclusivement
les mineurs c'est un phénomène qui
touche tous les réseaux et notamment
notre actualitté ce sont les réseaux
d'amérique du sud qui fonctionnent
quasiment exclusivement de cette manière
là en exploitant un grand nombre de
victimes
les associations et services sociaux
sont en difficulté leurs maraudes sur la
voie publique ne s'adressant qu'à une
petite partie émergée de l'iceberg de la
prostitution qui a une forte tendance à
l'ubs et risation c'est ainsi que toutes
les étapes de la prostitution sont
dématérialisés et dissimulé d'abord le
recrutement le recrutement des victimes
qui se fait par le biais de réseaux
sociaux ensuite la publication des
annonces à l'attention des clients qui
est souvent faite par les proxénètes
même sur des sites spécialisés
ensuite la mise en relation entre le
client et la victime la prise de rendez
vous qui se fait donc souvent par sms le
proxénète se chargeant en réalité du
standard de la victime
c'est là qu'on voit l'organisation on a
parfois 40 lignes qui sont gérées par un
seul groupe de proxénètes le client
croyant alors à tort échanges avec la
prostituée qu'il souhaite rencontrer la
location de chambres d'hôtel ou
d'appartements de courte durée se fait
également par l'intermédiaire de
plateformes sur internet et enfin ça a
été évoqué le contrôle de la victime qui
se fait aussi par l'intermédiaire de l'
échange de messages réguliers avec le
proxénète qui assoit ainsi son emprise
tente aussi bien que nos enquêtes sont
aujourd'hui complètement révolutionné et
elles doivent être double précédemment
nos enquêtes pouvait se concentrent ce
qu'ont tenté d'identifier les auteurs
afin de pouvoir les interpeller et ainsi
avoir un accès direct à leur victime
aujourd'hui il est essentiel pour les
enquêteurs de procéder à des actes
poussé tels que l' enquête sous
pseudonyme sur internet afin
d'identifier et localiser les victimes
des réseaux de traite qui se cache
derrière des pseudonymes sur des
annonces internet
ils ne répondent pas elle-même au numéro
de téléphone associé ce qui rend aussi
les maraudes même les maraudes sur
internet des associations parfois
extrêmement difficile voire inefficace
je précise ici d'ailleurs que nous nous
heurtons à une difficulté d'en quête
importante avec les plateformes de
location de logements de courte durée
qui se cachant derrière le droit du pays
de leur siège répondent peu ou pas à nos
réquisitions ne permettant pas la
localisation des victimes de manière
aisée sans ce travail et d'en quête il
devient difficile voire impossible de
projets sévices de protéger ses victimes
qui passent en dessous de tous les
radars
sauf de ceux d'une enquête fouillée
minutieuse le partenariat entre les
associations et la police n'en est que
plus indispensables la police donnant
accès aux associations par son enquête
aux victimes invisibles du système
prostitutionnel
mon dernier point ce sera le plus court
de la loi c'est la possibilité élargi
qu'a donné la loi concernant la saisie
et la confiscation des biens des
hauteurs de proxénétisme
en effet les enquêteurs ont la
possibilité de saisir en lien avec le
magistrat qui dirige l'enquêté
l'ensemble des biens appartenant aux
mis-en-cause de proxénétisme ou de
traite en vue de leur confiscation
éventuelles lors du jugement in fine et
les saisies ne s'élimine donc pas aux
moyens aux produits de l'infraction
on parle dans notre jargon de
confiscation total ce qui est absolument
essentiel pour un contentieux ou l'appât
du gain est le moteur principal des
malfaiteurs
le proxénétisme et la traite des êtres
humains sont en effet des trafics
particulièrement juteux nécessitant
contrairement à d'autres types
d'infractions peu ou pas
d'investissement initial privé les
malfaiteurs de leurs biens c'est à dire
que taper au portefeuille s'avère
particulièrement dissuasif et efficace
la loi 2016 a élargi cette possibilité
de confiscation aux biens dont le
proxénète ne serait pas titulaire au
propriétaire en titre mais dont il
disposerait librement les différents
services enquêteurs ont pris l'habitude
d'utiliser au quotidien cette puissante
arme juridique notamment pour la saisie
des immeubles ainsi les chiffres des
saisie des avoirs criminels dans le
domaine de la traite et du proxénétisme
en france de ces dernières années santé
sont éloquents en 2017 ce sont 5
millions 900 mille euros qui étaient ces
dans ce domaine par les services
enquêteurs en 2019 ce sont plus de 10
millions et je ne dispose là pour le
coup pas encore des chiffres complets
pour l'année 2011 une difficulté et a
souligné toutefois nos enquêtes
financières et patrimoniales montre que
l'argent issu du marché de la
prostitution est souvent réacheminés
vers le pays d'origine des réseaux de
prostitution où il est évidemment
réinvestis
[Musique]